[Music]
for decades
there has been a tug of war between
connectionism and
symbolism or between discrete and
continuous
or perhaps you might prefer the
terminology between type 1
and type 2. symbolism requires
symbol processing as the most suitable
model of cognition
which is to say the serial syntactical
and universal transformation of discrete
symbols
in computational algorithms or in plain
english
the kind of code that you write in
python could construct a valid model
of cognition the symbols or variables if
you like
serve as representations of external
reality in nlp
the symbolists would represent lexical
semantics
through an ontology or semantic network
typically manually created by
lexicographers
or domain experts on the other hand
connectionism regards parallel and
distributed information processing
in the form of vectors and tensors
as being the most salient model of
cognition
that is in other words the application
of artificial neural networks in my
opinion the duality between
discrete and continuous is fascinating
it seems to pervade absolutely every
single aspect
of reality itself now since the 1980s
when connectionist methods started
getting traction
a whole theory arose trying to postulate
an alternative
and unified theory of cognition
smelensky
rumor heart and mcclelland they devised
a new model of cognition which
is called the sub-symbolic paradigm
right so connectionist models may well
offer an opportunity to escape
the brittleness of symbolic ai systems
but
is it possible to marry them together
right with an integrative or hybrid
paradigm
what's interesting with almost all of
these integrative approaches
is that they use a type 1 model
as the first class citizen right many
are looking for ways to create a type 2
interface
within a type 1 model exactly as is the
case for transformers
and graph neural networks so all of the
dominant hybrid approaches
are much closer to connectionism than
symbolism
and personally i must say i'm quite
interested in charlay's conception
right which is almost turning on its
head having a first-class discrete model
in the inner loop
and the neural network in the outer loop
much like recent efforts in neural
program synthesis
so you basically embed meaning and
grammar all together in categorical
quantum mechanics
what you do get then is a quantum model
of language
it can be called a quantum model of
language i didn't like to use a term at
a time now i'm
totally unashamed to use the term i
think at the time was suddenly deep
learning start to boom boom boom boom
boom
and nobody nobody had any other interest
in deep learning everybody everybody was
obsessed with
learning why not put language on a
quantum computer
but will there are no quantum computers
yet
that's not true part i'm gonna work for
a company
called righty and i'm gonna build them
there
great that is really cool let's figure
out how that works
now professor bob kirk met professor
lambeck
in the late 1990s and a few years later
demonstrated his
categorial diagrammatic quantum
formalism
of quantum teleportation lambek
immediately recognized that these were
the same
thing as the pre-group category or
grammars
that he had been using in language it's
fascinating that
a chance encounter between two
scientists could elicit
a convergence of two completely
different strands of research
now a pre-group category or grammar it
consists of a lexicon of words
a set of types and relations between the
words and the types
it's a little bit like lego but for
language
right you can declare the connectivity
on the relations between the types for
example the word
met must plug into a noun on the right
side
and the left side a beautiful
diagrammatic calculus emerges when you
draw lines
between the contracting types when
they're connected together
now bob is a huge advocate of what he
calls
anti-cartesian togetherness it's a
paradigmatic
shift from reductionism to togetherness
right so take this instance of a verb
right a verb it connects to an
object a subject and the meaning of a
sentence
the meaning can't be decomposed into
parts it must be reasoned as a whole
just like entangled particles violate
independence and
collapse as a whole not as parts this is
something which is immediately
noticeable in bob's diagrammatic
calculus
the interesting thing about language is
that it's not really one-dimensional
it's broadcasted as a sequence of tokens
but those tokens have a hierarchical
self-referential relationship requiring
multiple dimensions to represent meaning
language is also weirdly discreet isn't
it
so bob and his collaborators were
inspired by smilenski's formalism of
sub-symbolic natural language processing
seeking to unify the symbolic and the
vector-based worlds
by casting an utterance into a
structured object representation
which is to say decomposing it into
symbols
and roles representing variable and
value bindings
and conjugations these can then be
projected
into a vector space via a tensor product
or an outer product
and conjugated by simply adding the
tensors together
now previously the nlp world was
dominated by linguists
and inspired by chomsky's idea of using
propositional deductive logic
as the starting point for their grammar
which is frankly antithetical to vector
spaces right
bob decided that this was overly onerous
and we actually needed to think about
the abstract structure of text itself
the flow of meaning between the words
the thing that inspired this the most
was when bob discovered that a lot of
the grammatical burden
actually vanished when we use his
quantum reasoning approach
to collapse the complexity of the
representations
the problem though is that these vector
spaces were tricky to work with
every grammatical structure would live
on an entirely different vector space
and you couldn't make them interact in
any way
the spaces were way too large they blew
up
exponentially with the number of
variables seen in the tensor products
which needed to be computed of course
remember the inner products can only be
computed if the tensors live on the same
space
which would mean that they would need to
have exactly the same grammatical
structure
so with lambex formalism you could
represent the grammar as a pre-group
with the vector spaces inside if you
organized them as a category this would
not only verify the grammatical
correctness of a sentence
but it could also project it into a
compositional vector space
so we're effectively conflating vector
space
meanings and typed logic for grammars
so here the types become vectors
themselves
participating in tensor products
evaluated over all of the possible type
assignments
the tensor product superposes the types
allowing them to interfere
constructively
and destructively to amplify or
attenuate different possible meanings
as more words across the text combine
the right meaning
the right interpretation should become
ever more pronounced so in this
conception the grammatical structure
becomes
an envelope over the vector space itself
what's interesting for us now is that
this isn't a machine learning conception
the
the roles and the symbols were
hard-coded by humans
but bob now thinks that deep learning
can extract the symbols and the types
from the text
and then his sub-symbolic formalism can
do the rest
now um bob argues that his nlp
conception becomes
a continuous generalization of montague
style boolean value of
you know propositional logic semantics
where the sentences are merely true or
false
in the same spirit bob argues that this
elicits the ability to have degrees
or probabilities of meaning something
which i'm fairly sure walid sabha and
the traditional gofund advocates would
scoff at
bob goes one step further and he
suggests that this new approach to
grammar might actually represent
you know an exciting new development in
the space perhaps one of the most
exciting new developments since montague
himself
now on the other hand we have quantum
computing
a notoriously difficult engineering
problem
drawing tens of billions of investment
dollars
from the world's largest corporations
and governments
they are fighting to capture a
marketplace
which is expected to reach 100 billion
dollars in the next decade
and not only is it hard to build a
quantum computer
it might turn out to be even harder to
program them
so far only a handful of useful quantum
algorithms have been designed
and configuring a quantum computer to
calculate
using those algorithms is itself a
monumental engineering problem
that will probably interestingly be
driven by machine learning procedures
bob has invented an interesting new
pictorial formalism for quantum
mechanics
called zx calculus he's been working on
it on the you know for the best part of
the last two decades
he's written several fascinating
textbooks on the subject
it allows almost anyone to reason about
quantum
circuits entanglement and quantum
teleportation
could nlp and quantum computing be a
match made in heaven
does it just so happen by cosmic
accident that nlp
is amenable to quantum computing bob
thinks that quantum entanglement can be
leveraged to dramatically collapse the
calculation complexity
of the superposition of possible
meanings of a sentence
using this lambect representation this
is because the compact closed category
allows us to use bob's diagrammatic
quantum calculus
to greatly simplify the computation
required
so you might argue that bob's approach
is actually just no different from
vector semantics and deep learning and
that he's essentially replaced vectors
with types
so his approach might suffer from the
same limitations of vector spaces in
general
namely that they lack abstract structure
and the structure that they do have is
not reversible
or invertible once a tensor composition
is obtained
its decomposition is undecidable which
is to say
we can't go back to the constituents so
doing so would require symbolic
variables and
and thus quantification so go-fi people
would still argue that a logical
calculus is required
in natural language processing the
symbolic or type 2 structure
allows us to extrapolate better fodor
himself argued that once a human
understands what mary loves joe means
they would also understand what mary
loves dave
means via extrapolation in other words
we need syntactic structure
and compositionality of symbols and
quantification this isn't to say that we
shouldn't use vectors at all
if we insist on assuming symbols vectors
are still a good way of representing
approximate meanings
vectors have a nice compositional
algebra but on the flip side
vectors are not templates they cannot
extrapolate
to infinitely different sentences or
account for different variables
scopes and quantifications so
bob would argue that the use of logic in
language
isn't propositional in spite of montagu
he thinks that
it's not based on the kind of discrete
causal structures that you would find in
perl for example
and that we should rethink what
interference means beyond the binary or
the true and false setting
bob would also argue that his approach
is not even committed to vectors right
they're they're experimenting with
continuous structures like
density matrices and even crazier stuff
which the category or framework allows
for bob would also be one of the first
people to denounce vector spaces right
following von neumann
who thought that they shouldn't be used
as a formalism for anything this is what
got bob started into the diagrammatic
approaches for quantum reasoning in the
first place
so the key concept for bob is that what
should really emerge from this
conversation today is the concept of
togetherness
or interaction dynamics are super
important
and also there are old results from
semantics and computer science
that propositional reasoning and
probabilities simply can't live in the
same world
they're completely different but we need
something new
to replace them anyway i really hope you
enjoyed the show today i've had so much
fun making it
remember to like comment and subscribe
we love reading your comments
and we'll see you back next week for
professor gary marcus
and professor lewis lan
peace up we had francois chalet on the
other week and he was saying that he
believes that
human brains are actually discreet first
right
on the inner loop so yeah the question
was the question was about uh
whether there is some similarity with
with catastrophe theory
like i can't remember his name um
there's a french french
mathematician who got a field medal for
that and and so
you see there's a lot of topology in
this nli and in these analysis of things
there
so that guy himself was very interested
in education and he was like
one of the mathematicians to put forward
in the strongest possible terms
that that development of reasoning of
people is not spatial initially it's not
like geometrical it's purely topological
it's like about pulling a rope on two
sides and it moves
without even having understanding about
different distances so kids don't even
understand the difference
between short and small and stuff
anymore you can test this with kids they
don't have an understanding of what fits
in what at a very young age
they only learn this later but they
already have some topological
understanding
and then i mean piaget did a lot of
experiments with these things
so it's becoming sort of a new i mean my
wife's in education especially
she's now starting to do experiments
with these things like again like like
the
sort of fundamental so the topology is
like a fundamental
i mean we wrote some paper like i've got
one paper in psychology journal about
that sort of stuff like
in physics where people analyze space
times
you've got sort of different layers
you've got like a causal layer and then
you bring in topological structure and
then geometrical structure and
it seems to be the same with humans that
the way we develop our understanding of
space
comes like with different layers of
structure and topology seems to be the
first one
like really this topological
understanding i mean i don't know much
about it but
i mean it makes sense to me i mean if
you look at a kit
it's clear that the sort of topology
stuff is something you understand
before they understand any joke anything
geometrical
i have a question which is uh because a
lot of a lot of what we talked about
today really has to do with
whatever we want to call it emergence
holism you know
togetherness it's all the same sort of
do you um
do you follow my sort of the
philosophical debate of
strong emergence like does is there such
a thing as strong emergence
do you believe that there is and and
what in your if so what is
say the the most crystal clear the best
case of strong emergence
i i don't really understand the
distinction in general very well right
i don't i don't really i mean i know i
know the definition but i don't really
understand it
to be honest it it doesn't seem so
dichotomic to me
i mean this i mean this whenever
whenever people call something strong or
weak or whenever they try to measure
something on the line
i usually sort of i don't understand
this
because for me things don't leave online
nothing lives on the line
definitely nothing nothing is binary
right and you can you know you can you
can formalize it in a way so
for example quantum entanglement to me i
think is
is a simple example like it's very clear
mathematically
yeah well the variables are not
separable you know flat out they're just
not separable you have to analyze the
entangled state
as a whole you can't analyze the
individual
probabilities you can't assume
independence that just doesn't work and
so
to me that's the definition of a strong
emergence yeah you know we're being
maintained
at stake i mean my statement then is
pretty much there is nothing else and
strong around
emergency nature to tell me something
which is not strongly emergent
explain me something something i'm not
talking about theories i'm not talking
about mathematical descriptions
i'm talking about real phenomena tell me
a real phenomena that's not strongly
emergent
well i've seen that argument made for
example um
you know by by other physicists that
that the only behavior in the universe
is
emergent behavior that we don't even
have access actually to the lowest level
of
the tiniest most fundamental things and
we never will that the only behaviors we
observe
are actually emergent behaviors but i
mean staying away from kind of such a
strong
dichotomy like you know because it's not
that useful to say everything is
emergent because then we can't
can't you know talk about things that
are not emergent you know to me it seems
like quantum entanglement
is a canonical example of something
that's strongly emergent
and yet you'll find people like right
that are so
their identity is so caught up in
reductionism
that they'll try and find some semantic
way to argue that no no no no yeah
yeah i mean the emergency that that all
that that also in itself was so bad in
the 90s for theoretical physics these p
these people still fighting all this
sort of quantum stuff
trying to put us in a classical world
that also did a lot of damage to the
foundational stuff that did a lot of
damage to the community
and they're starting again but okay but
now i think the quantum computing is
strong enough to actually
kind of like that people can completely
neglect that sort of
but i mean i mean what the way i see
quantum mechanics what it taught us was
that
we have been trying to make everything
look
non-emergent throughout all of history
and it's sort of
basically you can't get away with that
really stop doing that you just can't
get away with it
here's the proof but and part of the re
part of this obsession with this this
non-emergent stuff and this cartesian
stuff
is why do humanities and all that are so
far behind
in sort of scientific practices of
mathematical nature because the
mathematicians and all the formalisms
were never suited for these people and
the sort of substance they deal with
it was never suited because you have to
go to this emerge of course
like what is it what's interesting about
two people they're not describing them
individually
you know it's not very interesting
like like it's it's all about like the
emerging stuff which happens if you put
two things together
and and the mats mats is only starting
to go so now there is a new
new community which is called applied
category theory community and that
that's the sort of stuff they're looking
at
but i mean not not just social also like
a
uh like in engineering because
engineering needs that sort of math too
you know
sure yeah like a steel bar has you know
rigidity because it's an emergent
property it's not a property of iron
atoms
welcome back to the machine learning
street talk youtube channel
uh with me tim scarf and my two
compadres dr
yannick lightspeed culture and mit
phd dr keith duggar now
in today's show we have bob kirk who is
a celebrated physicist
he's been a physics and quantum
professor at oxford university
for the last 19 years he's particularly
interested in structure
which is to say logic order and category
theory
he's well known for work involving
compositional distributional models of
natural language meaning
and don't worry we'll go into what we
mean by that later it's uh there's a lot
of jargon already
he's fascinated with understanding how
our brains work he's supervised
50 phd students at oxford and he's been
cited
over 7 000 times he's got an h index of
40.
and last but not least bob was recently
appointed as the chief
scientist at cambridge quantum computing
now bob argues for a paradigmatic shift
from reductionism
to togetherness he thinks that the
concept of togetherness
or abstract systems thinking has
suffered in the sciences
and especially in physics where all of
the effort has been spent
describing the individual you know
reinforcing fractionation at every
possible opportunity
he cites the theory of everything in
physics as being the most egregious
manifestation of this dogma
indeed our own understanding of the
human brain has already made it
abundantly clear that we should be
studying brains in ice you know
not in isolation but rather their
interactional dynamics
now bob thinks that interactions between
systems and quantum mechanics
actually carries over naturally to how
word meanings interact
in natural language he argues that this
interaction kind of embodies the
phenomenon of quantum teleportation
now is this a revolutionary idea or is
it a gratuitous use of quantum reasoning
well this is something that we're going
to be discussing in the show today now
bob absolutely hates symbolic reasoning
with a passion
he has dedicated much of his career to
alternative
pictorial formalisms for reasoning about
category or logic and quantum circuits
bob invented zx calculus it's a
graphical calculus for revealing
the compositional structure within
quantum circuits to show
entanglement states and protocols in a
visually succinct
but logically complete way von neumann
himself
didn't even like his own symbolic
formalism of quantum theory
despite it being widely used now zx
calculus makes it so
simple and visual that even high school
students
can perform quantum reasoning which is
usually the preserve of
hilbert space aficionados so anyway and
zx calculus is outlined in exquisite
detail in bob's 900-page book
which is called picturing quantum
processes and he also has a new book
coming out describing his zx calculus
which i've had the pleasure of reading
by the way
aimed at high school students so keep an
eye out for that anyway bob um it's an
absolute honor and a pleasure
welcome to the show tell us about your
intellectual journey over the last two
decades
okay where do we start so
uh i started off as a very
non-intellectual teenager
but i was politically active and i
started the only way
anybody would ever listen to me was to
go study the most difficult thing at
university so i started engineering
then i got a course in quantum physics
and i hated it i just deeply deeply
deeply hated it so i didn't want to do
it so i went to study architecture
then i had an internship in the real
world and i it worked and i absolutely
hated it so i said i don't want to be in
the real world okay so then i studied
physics anyway
and maths and uh i kind of then learned
that vlogman like you said earlier
kind of hated his own quantum formalism
too so on that point i went into a
journey of
trying to come up with a new quantum
formalism this wasn't a particularly
popular thing to do in the 90s when the
theory of everything people which you
also
mentioned at the time strength
theoreticians were completely taking
every single job in theoretical physics
so i ended up on the unemployment market
i tried my luck as an artist again
completely failed
i was then very lucky to end up in a
computer science department in oxford in
for the single reason that they want to
learn some physics there and i happen to
know some category theory and logic
which these computer scientists know
they took me in six years later i was
faculty
i built out a big group so i mean the
group at a time of leaving was about 50
people i mean it's one of the largest
birth quantum groups and
category theory and logic groups in the
world i guess uh
i became faculty's 2006 i'm full
professor 2008
and then recently i felt it was clear
that our work
that we had been doing was starting to
move into quantum industry
with companies like if you see presence
of that now in companies like google and
ibm
so is it probably time for me to
mingle in the real world a little bit
too and so that's what i started doing
and also i got really disappointed with
the way universities were going
to add that too that's that's how i find
myself where i am
now but i've always wanted to be a rock
star but completely fail
could you expand just a bit on on your
disappointment in universities
i'm just really curious about that oh so
i don't want to go in too much politics
here
because it's still uh ways heavy on my
shoulders because it's a fairly recent
experience but like the
the incredible increase in management
structure basically has changed
universities from home to academics
to some brand that uses academics as
resources
it's it's just and you see these things
now also in the uk happening
with management's closing entire
departments for example
maths and computer science are being
closed in leicester
at the cost of like a big artificial
intelligence department so so
that's that's sort of so i mean this is
probably going to be part of our
discussion but i see a big danger here
coming from the
from the machine learning sort of site
which is very similar
to the disaster which happened in the
90s coming from the string theory side
that they are like in the heads of like
stupid managers
are gonna push away a lot of other stuff
because they only see one thing in the
news
i saw something very similar so part of
the reason i eventually found my way
out of academics is you know i used to
be naive and i thought it was really the
ivory tower where the only thing that
mattered was
the pursuit of truth and if you had
sufficient evidence or a proof of
something that
everyone around you just had to accept
it because now you have a you know
proof for that but you know i started to
find out that it's really
heavily influenced by by money and
politics you know just like every other
kind of
human endeavor it's it's it's so so i
can talk about my 20 last years in the
in the uk like in the beginning it was
academic paradise here really it was
academic paradise especially at a place
like oxford
you genuinely like you you it wasn't
really entirely ivory tower but you had
entire freedom and what got respected
were really cool great ideas
because they allowed me in a computer
science department to develop this
diagrammatic approach to quantum
stuff which which was really like the
sort of freedom
you're hoping for in even an ideal
academic environment but gradually
uh politicians start to get their hands
on funding organizations
and that then the funding organization
were made more powerful
more more management staff they they got
all bigger egos and they start to think
that they were actually
running the the academic world not the
academics they became pretty arrogant
too
and these are carried over to the
university management's because they
were then interacting with this funding
management
and and i think the battle is already
lost now
i think the battle is really lost and
then also department heads become
equally
stupid after a while and and i mean
for me i mean i saw it going worse and
worse but then
the attempt of me to trying to get a
split position half academics half
private sector really showed me how bad
it was yeah i had to
one of my uh well let me let me step
back a little bit
someone i knew at mit who was a
professor there
i don't want to sufficiently narrow it
to to get it down but
it had a theory that actually this the
ball on this kind of got rolling a
little bit
post world war ii at least in the united
states because
in a large part world war ii was one
through technology right it was it was a
technological battle
as much as anything else and so post
world war ii at least
the united states government said wow
this technology stuff is great
like we need more of it we got to start
dumping money
you know into into research and of
course they need some way of figuring
out who to get the money to
right and and so at that time they could
look at academic publications and say
well you've got
10 publications in this journal and
you've got 15 over here so we can
have a gauge by which we can measure you
know who we who we might allocate
money to and of course game
theoretically this is now going to
result in
in a uh you know a kind of unintended
side effect where oh
if they're using papers as the measure
of publications is the measure by which
money is doled out
we got to get some more publications and
so you start to see this
explosion and eventually exponential
explosion and
journals and numbers of publications and
and everything because of this kind of
you know money corrupting it is a game
now and also the way things are set up
with grants and all that
i'm sure that it is this is a losing
game the amount of time people are
putting in grant not only sort of in
work time but stress time
psychological damage and all that like
like like broken marriages
just because of the amount of stress and
it's like you either get it or you don't
get it
there's nothing in the middle and the
majority doesn't get it so they're just
working their ass off without any reward
just stress
and then a management i mean i know
examples of people who didn't get tenure
because they didn't get a huge major
grant
while the chances together are so small
it's it's just it's all absurd and
i mean and it's been getting worse also
also
you mentioned poppy pop publication
thing it's a game it's not about what
are
the really most promising long-term
pieces of research what is the stuff
which people are still going to talk
about 20 years from now 50 years from
now
no it's like who get that paper right
now i mean
you gave an example of the x characters
if you look for example this got
blatantly rejected wherever we submitted
this for a while if you now look at the
sort of
things which got accepted for these
conferences these top conferences
just in citations well this is not
really even citation
uh hungry work we got way more citations
and all
other papers together that got accepted
really what's the solution to that
though
because and we were speaking to mark
serafin recently and he says that now
academics has changed to
you almost need to be a media company
you know open ai as a media company
and what we're doing now actually is is
a form of mediation
so do academics need to be much better
at telling
narratives and stories about their work
uh
i think academics as we knew it is never
going to come back anymore
that that's my that's my belief and uh
in in general like anybody in society
these sort of skills
indeed need to become part part of it at
least of part of a team or something
like that there's just no way around it
just no way around it uh i mean i mean
i'm sure
so some branches of mathematics where
they still solve like these incredibly
difficult
problems for which you have to be pretty
much an autistic
like whatever that's gonna stay that's
gonna stay i'm pretty sure there are
some things which
just can happen only in an ivory tower
or in some little village somewhere in
russia you know
uh so so these things are i think gonna
stay but the sort of
more exciting stuff is going to move
more i mean this has been going like
like
for example in theoretical physics
you've got institutes like the perimeter
institute for terrorists or physics in
in waterloo
so more and more private research
institutes are going to come out of the
ground because it's going to be the only
way
to get kind of protected from all the
other pressures
i mean i don't i can't put forward the
model but clearly the old model is not
working anymore
i mean it's it's interesting what what
you're saying
that this also in computer science comes
from the ai
departments and i i see this in
real time you know as a as a very recent
graduate
of academia during the time
i was here so from the beginning of my
phd
the institute of machine learning within
the department of computer science it
just grew
from like one professor to to
three or four actually two to three at
that point
and now this institute is
like almost as big as the rest of the
department together
so just professors get hired and hired
and hired for machine learning
and not even that but all the other
groups
even though they are not machine
learning they might be systems or
networks or security
they're doing machine learning too like
they're they're like you know how
you know how can we how can we apply
neural networks to
malware detection or to routing traffic
and so on
um you know i mean this is to some
extent justified
because there is some sort of i would
call this an edison moment
going on with machine learning i mean
the ideas aren't really new
the whole idea of neural network has
been around for i don't know how long
but this is the moment just like edison
could put uh like a city on light
that that actually is ready and the
machines are there to actually bring
this in society in a way that's actually
gonna be transformational for society
so it makes a lot of sense that this is
given a lot of attention and all that
but but now i hear some figures like in
the in the public media speak that like
a
machine learning is going to blow away
and you were disciplining signs and all
that
i can and stuff like that which was what
the strength theoreticians were saying
about theoretical physics
and that's of course pretty dumb like i
mean it's great i mean we should embrace
it's a fantastic uh
fantastic tool the learning tool but it
is what it is
just like electricity didn't blow away
all the other sciences when
when edison lighted up the city you know
i mean it it it enriched them all people
could just work it's called suddenly
work in the dark you know
you could do your philosophy in the dark
because edison gave you light
so it did help the it did help all other
scientists
and uh of course like the we've seen
this revolution in uh
i mean when when when i think about cs
revolution what happened between like
90 and and 2010 with i.t
and internet and mobile telephony and
the availability of
laptops that's transformed science like
crazy
but it didn't make computer science like
swallowing up or
other sciences no it's like it was an
amazing tool that was provided
so i'm saying machine learning in a
similar way there's of course
conceptually
that there's conceptually a very new
idea there this was
this was the same with the the
sophisticated computer science operation
systems that you have on the phone this
was also revolutionary
sort of yeah know-how and you structure
the new ideas that went into that
i i was meaning to transition a bit
because
this this thing you know of of one
discipline coming in be it string theory
being it be it ai
that sort of pushes out all the other
research
some degree is of course justified but
it almost seems like
a bit too much at points it seems like
you're making
a similar point in the world of natural
language processing
where you know the dominant approaches
are sort of
uh let's just all put this into vectors
and let's just have them
linearly and non-linearly intermingle
with each other until we get a number
out at the end could you
could you you know shed a bit of light
on what you think about the current
developments i expected i would actually
be confronted about that but you're
actually
feeling you didn't mean to spook so give
it time i mean i've seen i've seen
things evolved because
uh the way i mean i had no background in
natural language at all there's a lot
like sort of
a funny story is that i was a postdoc in
2000 at mcgill
uh and i get i went there with a plastic
bag and i had no place to stay
so uh jim lombeck who's like uh the
father of categorical grammars going
back to the 50s and all that he said oh
bob you can stay in my house it's big
and i live alone
it was at a time in the mid 80s so it
was talking to me
i knew him from all the work from the
foreign categories here you see i'm
doing
language stuff again and blah blah blah
i didn't they take any attention
then a few five then uh four or five
years later i was giving a talk at
mcgill about my diagrammatic quantum
formalism categorical diagrammatic
quantum formalism and i was explaining
call them teleportation
and he said hey these are pre-group
categorical grammars
he was sitting there himself like and he
saw me explain teleportation and i said
these are pre-group categorical grammars
there is nothing mystical about
that because you mentioned this in your
introduction that i said teleportation
but lombic immediately
recognized the grammatical structure
when i was just trying to explain
teleportation in our new way
uh i mean i didn't pick this up but and
then
one or two years later steve clark who
who was until recently at deepmind and
now just joined my team
he was then faculty at oxford he
explained the problem
at the time that there was this complete
uh separation between people
starting to do vector model it was not
at all that the neural nets were
dominating at a time by no means
and then more traditional people using
because he had done a lot of parsing
or and so people using like a
grammatical gadget
and uh steve pullman was too at oxford
and he had sort of put the challenge to
steve like how can we combine those two
and then steve had been reading a little
bit in small smolensky like the
connections
moleski was using cancer products to
like bring in some way grammar and
meaning together
but i mean it was kind of a
very hard to handle because each
sentence with a different grammatical
structure would live in a completely
different space so you couldn't
make them interact in any way and and
the space is very humongous you ended up
doing something like fox space which is
spacing with the huge space in which
physicist the quantum field theory you
know
so so we then came up together with
steve in a very elegant
with an area very elegant way to combine
the two and this really came from the
fact
like lumbeck remarked that two have
exactly the same structure
grammar in the form of pre-groups and
vector spaces
if you organize them in a category which
means you don't have just single vector
spaces but you also compose
multiple together so if you've got a
string of words in a sentence then you
kind of compose them together in a
bigger space
and uh if you do it like that and then
you respect your sp
your spaces also respect the grammatical
types from the grammar theories
then you can just like use your
grammatical structure as an envelope
it's an envelope is i think a good word
an envelope on top of your vector space
structure which
guides grammatical compositions
so we got ourselves an algorithm then
and we were really excited about that
and that time we we got like
a lot of attention we were on the cover
of new scientists and all that with that
stuff which was really crazy for me
because i never made a cover
of new scientists with any physics i
knew nothing about linguistics whatever
sort of
and then we were in scientific american
so so it got a lot of attention but then
then boom happened and you know what the
name of boom was
the name of boom was machine learning so
suddenly people stopped
i mean all the attention and the energy
was of course going there
now we also had a little problem at a
time and uh
the little problem we had is if you
start combining vector spaces with
tensor products
they become very quickly very big they
come
they blow up exponentially so so the
people
working with us who were doing the
experiments they had really a hard time
like building the tensors of
things like verbs because these were
products of multiple spaces and it was
really hard to get this properly on a
classical machine
uh then we've all i mean i then start to
write a book
this book
and and so to some extent the attention
around
this approach went down a bit and my
interest also went more to cognitive
modelling personally like i think i saw
this
i really wanted to more understand our
brave word but then like
quantum computers came around and i mean
we've always known that if there would
be quantum computers
this stuff wants to live on a quantum
computer because essentially it's a
quantum model
can we address we'll address the quantum
stuff later so i i think that's that's
the yeah
it goes hand in hand well just for now
let's try let's try and disentangle um
the two for if you're if you're pardon
the pun but yeah i'm i'm really
interested in this because um
there has been a kind of revolution in
nlp over the last decade or so and and
actually there are many people who would
argue that it's a complete dead end this
whole vector approach
you know deep learning and so on but for
decades post chomsky
um the theories and the models were
derived from the field of linguistics
right and they were quite introspective
and rules based in general and actually
a lot of the stuff you're talking about
this lambet calculus or
category or grammar it kind of derived
from montague and chomsky and all this
kind of stuff
so um it changed in the 1990s everything
became increasingly empirical and
statistical and data driven
and i think the watershed moment for me
was mikalov's word to vec model which
popularized the idea of placing words
and sentences in a euclidean vector
space and
the results were pretty impressive and
they afforded a whole bunch of clever
text processing especially since the
transformers evolution of this idea
which
uh arguably extends the embeddings
beyond just a bag of words but
introducing some structure
um but anyway you have an entirely
different view of this so as i say
you're going back to this category or
grammar and and so on
and um you know i think we should move
back to the chomsky view now the thing
is
these aren't methods not exactly not
exactly you can continue but i just want
to say at this point not exactly but
okay
just like i mean if we did go back to
this
um this grammar view of natural language
processing i think the reason that we
abandoned it were there there were quite
a few edge cases right
doesn't always work this has to do with
what one means by
symbolic reasoning or let's say non
let's let me call it non-statistical
because i want to put a much bigger
umbrella there than the sort of going
back to
so of course a lot of the traditional
work like from lumbeck and chomsky and
all that
they they had a very propositional logic
starting point so a lot of the sort of
structures were very similar to
propositional logic
now one doesn't have to sort of do
empirical work or anything like that if
one really looks careful in the
mathematical structure then we'll see
that there is a complete
mismatch a complete and utter mismatch
between on the one hand
vector space like structures and on the
other hand
propositional deductive systems they
just don't they don't fit together
there's no way to get the two together
so
if you want to sort of take on one end
anything like symbolic propositional
systems be it like categorical grammars
or anything like that on the
other hand vector space you're never
going to get them together in a decent
way
that's why i think any attempt of people
to
combine them just just approaching them
like that
was bound to fail these are these are
things computer scientists understood
for a very long time
on a very abstract level like if you
want to combine probabilistic semantics
with non-deterministic semantics
it doesn't fit together it doesn't work
they just
they don't like it so someone has to
start at a different level
so so our starting point is not anything
deductive propositional symbolic or
anything like that
our starting point is a what we call
compositional structure
and and that's really try try to see
uh how things flow within a sentence
without having any
logical presumptions or anything like
that about that
just see how things flow in each other
and
this is very recent work which which
which actually we're just finishing the
papers
uh for now we actually went back to look
at grammatical structure lumber
ketchumsky and all that and we saw that
this is full
of unnecessary bureaucracy from the
perspective i was just talking about
like just understanding what are the
sort of
backbones of the flow of meanings
between different words
also within text so a lot of that is
uh and now this brings me back to the
grammar grammatical paradigm
that we humans poor creatures can only
speak one-dimensional
we can only put words in a string
we can't put we can't speak like words
in a two-dimensional
sort of surface we can't do that but if
you carefully analyze grammar
then you see that the real essence what
the what's really universal
lives in a plane it doesn't live on a
line
and you may think okay therefore it's
more complex because it's
two-dimensional no it's actually you
take something two-dimensional and you
squash it into one dimension
and then there's a lot of order
bureaucracy which comes in because you
have to decide what comes for what
and as you know in different languages
different decisions have been made
made on this bureaucracy for example on
the other hand
these decisions also come with stylistic
options options on how to organize
different things to do your poetry so
you can get
your rhyming word at the end and all
that so there's a lot of positives about
this bureaucracy
but it's it makes it incredibly complex
to handle
in any scientific manner so that aspect
alone i think is a reason of the big
failure
of trying to combine or integrate
this sort i mean this is something
machine learning is really good about
this bureaucracy
like learning styles learning stylistic
features they're very good at
do this with images and so so that's
stuff you don't want to put in your
fundamental structure
so we're not we're now so you know how
we discover this
trying to by putting grammatical
structure on a quantum computer when we
have to put it in circuits form
we actually saw that a lot of garbage
from the grammatical calculate vanished
it was it was lost it was lost so
it was kind of accidental by forcing the
length the grammar
into a quantum circuit that we saw that
actually and so
so my my new attempt there which is
still very much developing is like to
start from this
i would call this machine grammar this
two-dimensional grammar that's how a
machine that's how machines want to talk
to each other
with some sort of grammatical content
and it's so much simpler
than the sort of usual all the stuff
like
lumbeck chomsky montague is so much way
more complicated than necessary
could you maybe give us an example to
make this a bit
explicit you know i i see like the point
that i understand so far is that
let's let's assume for a moment that
language
is really good or or would be really
simply displayed in two dimensions and
then
you know since we can only put words one
after another we we sort of have to
with all this complicated stuff um
it is not really concrete to me yet
there are pictures you have to draw a
picture so so so
just to give you a simple example if
you've got the sandals like alice ellis
loves bob
uh you got two ellen agents alice and
bob so this is what the story is about
so think of a circuit where where where
you're i mean i'm thinking some sort of
quantum circle
so you've got your two lines they're
alis and bob so you start off there is
no connection between elizabeth
we don't know who else is we don't know
or think of it like so maximal noise
okay suddenly the sentence conveys a new
idea to us
alice loves bob so it's as if there is a
gate
like a logic gate that now acts on alice
and bob and connect
them like i see not gate it entangles
them okay next sentence
bob loves claire too oh that's another
gate between bob and claire
next sentence alice slaps bob
of course she's not happy with declare
situation that's another sense
so and and the meanings throughout these
texts the meanings of alice are evolving
you know bob and alice are evolving and
they get entangled with each other
because of the new relationships
emerging and we
okay this is a very simple example for
from simple
subject object verbs but we got an
algorithm to translate all of english
to these so could i could i touch on
that then because i think that's that's
a wonderful example so i think the
genius of montagu was that he showed
that alice could be
replaced by any other entity that the
grammar allowed right any other noun
phrase so you could
replace alice with a girl in the sixth
grade or sixth grade with red hair and a
long ponytail or some beautiful girl
from my school so that that was that was
what the formalism was was about so to
say
the meaning would be fixed
yeah so i mean i mean this is not
entirely true anymore here because we
have to keep track on who alice is
throughout the text so so in the
montague stuff
you abstracted the way like of a of of
this is just a noun type so it's for us
very important which which different
nouns are
so we have to do some resolution there
somewhere some resolution of it
but but the more important thing is they
also had something like a unique
sentence type that doesn't hold for us
anymore neither
because the sentence type will be
determined by the sort of nouns
which a query or sentence and and so the
circuit actually
the gate the gate applies to those nouns
which appear in the center so
so it's a little bit more syntactic
structure we so we have to label our
nouns
in order to do what we do we have to be
flexible with sentence type because if
you've got an intransitive verb
sentence type will typically be a single
noun if you got a transitive verb it
will be a double noun if you get the
intensity verb it will triple nouns so
so there is a variation there
there's a variation in that because one
of the one of the big difficulties we
had initially
in our experiments with the our model
which combined grammar meaning is
we didn't know what the sentence type
was we had no
good candidate for a sentence type and
the story i'm just telling now with the
circuit souls all that
there is no real sentence type is kind
of the scope
the scope of the part of the world
where your sentence applied to so it's
local while in the old approach it was a
global thing it was sort of the universe
conceptually speaking you can never deal
with something like that because it's
infinitely large
conceptually speaking that's why i mean
montague semantics was really just
trying to squeeze logic back into
language quantifiers
and all that stuff and that's exactly
where i think
it works really bad when you go to
vectors so most of the montague stuff is
really common if you pass defectives you
can't retain that
okay so you know earlier you kind of
made this
uh reference to the sort of uh
propositional paradigm
if you will kind of imposes all this
garbage that can sort of be
you know abstracted or eliminated when
it's kind of in the the quantum paradigm
but
you know part of the reason for the
development of those paradigms was that
like tim brought up
if you instead that sentence said
something like a girl in the sixth grade
with blonde hair
you know loves bob you're not going to
actually be able to resolve
the meaning of that until much further
on like in your circuit
you know it's gonna have to maintain a
bunch of low level entanglement
that much further on maybe seven layers
up in the analysis or something
needs to get resolved so it's kind of
like the garbage actually has just gone
from top down to bottom up
it's like now we're maintaining a bunch
of garbage bits at the bottom that are
entangled that actually much later on
will
will be eliminated you know is that fair
yeah yeah yeah yes exactly so so one of
the nice thing of
uh of a quantum like formalism and which
goes back to the neumann
is that uh it it
so so vectors everybody knows what
vectors are like and then von neumann
realized very early on when developing
quantum mechanics there are many
situations that you don't know exactly
which vector you're dealing with
so you so something happens that you
don't know exactly which factor
so you invent a distinct density
matrices density matrices are a way
to encode ambiguity on top of vector
spaces
so it's intrinsic in our approach to i
mean i think it's the way forward to
actually use density matrices instead of
vectors
so they have a lot of advantages first
of all they allow you to encode
ambiguity so whatever ambiguity
be beat with pronoun resolution or be it
with like
lexical ambiguity it's it's all implicit
in these density matrix formalism and
you can wait
until you get the results at the later
stage so you just carry the different
options around
until they get resolved this is
something we actually did experiments
with in 2012
2013 to the extent you can do them on a
classical computer because again your
space has become bigger
again density matrix you tense of two
spaces a
quantum computer comes for free if
you've got normal vectors you've got
density matrix too
if you've got like a if you've got
separable vectors you got entangled
vectors too
all comes from free so it's so it's a
big part of this story to make it
feasible
so a couple of points on on this um
by the way the main reason why i think
deep learning is broken and then
our friend dr walid suburb has certainly
influenced my view on this is
is the missing text problem i'm not sure
if you've heard about this but in
language we don't say everything we mean
right so for example the corner table
wants a beer we know that the corner
table is a person we've done that
deductive reasoning so
spoken language is extremely ambiguous
it's actually a form of compression you
know we transmit the minimum amount of
information
and the receiver can decompress the
meaning using reasoning out of all of
the possible
meanings right so using your grammar and
formalism for nlp is in some sense
ignoring this key problem right because
being able to do the semantics is not
helpful
if you don't have all the information in
the first place nlu is about
uncovering in my opinion the single
human thoughts
behind an utterance and this formalism
by the way um
um inspired by montague he himself
admitted that
figuring out different meanings in
different contexts was not what he was
even working on he was working on
building a kind of formal natural
language compiler he admitted that there
would need to be an understanding module
on the top
so this is something that affects deep
learning as well but surely it affects
your approach as well
sure sure yeah i mean
so from the start the sort of
experiments we had been doing was always
focusing on ambiguity so there's
different levels of ambiguity
so there's first the ambiguity of like a
bank can be a queen can be a rock band a
queen
can be a royal like me can be a bee and
so that's level one ambiguity
then then you get ambiguity of parsing
like if i say black metal fan
this can be a metal device
and this can also be uh yeah somebody
goes to a black metal concert and if you
look at it like they parse differently
to start they pass differently the the
grant they're too deep they're not just
different means they're different
grammatical structures so you need to be
able to keep that into account and and
the sort of
if if you think of your vector space
formalism as part of
of the way people have set up a quantum
formalism we've tested matrix there's no
problem with that
quantum information theory is all about
dealing with these ambiguities
so you got a channel a channel is always
noisy it's always mixed you always got
ambiguities and all that
so formally you can actually deal with
these things
uh we actually are now starting to put
this on in experiments the quantum
computers aren't good enough so
we're putting this on classical machines
the only the only thing we can really do
at the moment
we're putting down classical machines
and we're starting to play around with
this but i know
the the places where uh where where this
formalism
at successes the most successes in
experimentally so far
was about disambiguation and and things
to do with
ambiguity it's been pretty good at that
from the start
so but we haven't pushed this fair
enough but i completely agree with
so what you're talking about now is the
ambiguity of a developing piece of text
for example
where you don't have where there's lots
of stuff you don't know
and maybe the black metal fan only
occurs like 10 lines later
and so so you really need to go back fix
you
carry your possible grammatical parsings
around and and
like in some sort of three think of it
as a tree with your possibilities
and then later branches of the trees
vanish away but the thing about density
matrices and and what's called
completely positive map is that
all that stud stuff got get bundled
together in one map
all these branches get bundled together
in one map and they exploit the linear
structure for that
they actually exploit the linear
structure to do this in an economic way
that's an invention from von neumann
from the 1920s
which which which is remarkable to me
that that piece of
math has never been used outside of
physics it's it's it's shocking
it's shocking especially since everybody
is now working with vectors everywhere
i think what what there is there is a
level of ambiguity on
on top of that and maybe maybe uh tim's
point was more to that in that
in a lot of text if you just read the
text
and you can parse it perfectly like i
can give you
the parse tree you know all of the i can
give you all the references and every
all of that all the meanings of the
ambiguities of words there is still
a lot of things that is not anywhere in
the text
right where you need to know the world
so like
when when tim tells me something he
makes some assumptions about who i
am and what i know and then he doesn't
say the things anymore
like you know he he texts me like you
know we're on in 60 minutes
like this this means nothing if it's not
in the context of
us being you know so how yeah how
how does this go into a system that
sort of deals in
in this in this circuit structure i
think
the information is not in the data i
think that's
really so to some extent i mean
part part of this is embodiment so one
of the things we learned from the old
generation from older generation ai's
the need for embodiment
so one thing we are we are working on
now so i mentioned density matrices as
one
kind of alternative to vector meanings
so another thing which again i'm like
working on literally today is like
replacing vector spaces vector space
meaning with something which is more
like a
uh giving giving giving the structure of
the space or the representation space
the illusion that it actually has a body
a body that can move in physical space
above a body that can observe physical
space around it so that you can actually
point two things
which is a little bit like what you were
just referring to with the studio
think that the ability to for example
use your arm at some point
uh to smell to to to to hear
to to taste so we're building new spaces
which have like taste and i mean some of
this is based on work by
garden force so it's a so this is this
cognitive psychologist who came up with
certain convex spaces for representing
things which are much closer to our
human senses so what you want to do then
is try to learn your stuff relative to
these spaces
again i'm not saying i'm not talking
about i keep saying i'm not talking
about going back to rule-based
bring propositional reasoning about
space no nothing like that
so you bring in the context of space
space has a structure there's a hell of
a lot of structure like
just just read euclid's book there's a
hell of a lot of stuff going on there
but you don't want to stick all the the
rules of euclid's booking your system
no you just teach you just tell the
system well instead of a vector space
part of our representation space is
three three plus one d physical space we
live in
let's learn again that space and then
probably gonna get inferences which come
from the structure of the space
and the way the space is related to
taste so if close close to the loo it
stinks
that's stuff you want to get i think
this is fascinating because
the the first thing is there's some
question about whether we should have um
a discrete inner loop or a continuous
inner loop because this whole idea of
vector spaces
um as you say that there might be
ambiguity
in the representation but certainly in
the original human thought behind a
nutrients there is no ambiguity at all
it's a binary decision there was
one meaning no degrees of freedom no
ambiguity whatsoever
so um you're talking about projecting
into these
spaces and with the missing information
problem
vector spaces aren't enough you have to
perform something like a syllogism or
some basic reasoning to
fill in the information as a function of
some common knowledge
so you don't you can't just have the
vector spaces right you need something
else
yes exactly yes exactly exactly though i
mean and so so the way we think about
these spaces now is you could
all these different components like
physical space maybe smells maybe taste
maybe other sort of modes of
representation and then
again like most most vector space
representations are fairly monolithic
so you get your big space in which you
represent your different meanings
it didn't change that much much since
like the bag of words model there
like the way we think of this is you got
these different factors of your spaces
and all the things between them are
entangled for example a banana
a banana i mean if a banana is green
it's going to be bitter
and it's going to be hard so there are
these different correlations between the
different spaces if it's black
it's going to be very soggy and and
slimy and whatever
if it's yellow it's going to be fairly
sweet and tasty
so so you've got these relationships
across across these different sort of
factors
and that's going to give you like
entailment power
and predictive entailment power that's
the idea of course these are ideas we're
just starting to play around with i have
to i mean we
they were in papers of us like four or
five years ago but but we're starting to
only now
play around this with experimentally and
it's it's going to give a completely
different paradigm now i'm not going to
say i'm not gonna say that
so so the way i think about new science
is
the most stupid thing you can do if you
come up with something new
is gonna sort of directly compete with
whatever already exists
because a new thing will tell
will tell you it by itself what it wants
to be used for
and this may not be necessarily the same
thing as the state of the art is doing
now
it may be a completely different thing
for what it is i mean if you look at the
history of science
it's always been like that people i mean
people people
people invented classical mechanic to to
to actually to sail with their boats
following the stars you know that was
that was that was the purpose
that was the purpose of like like uh
copernicus and
kepler it was about coming up with good
maps for both and by the way
because we're talking statistically
driven stuff here ptolemy's model
was much better than either copernicus
and kepler
ptolemy's model going back like 800
years before
was was statistically purely was
byzantine culture statistically driven
uh
approach was way better than anything
copernicus and kepler ever did
as far as using ships are using the the
data in ships went
but you know i mean people don't realize
this but um
uh ptolemy knew relativity
in some way because the data represented
like relativistic corrections
it did it was just statistical data so
they were they were doing curfitting
they were
doing perfecting on episcopals so so i
mean i've had some discussions
the sort of discussion we now have
against the sim
between the symbolism and and so so i
like to use the word aware
i'm sort of saying like our system is
grammar aware and uh the thing i was
more recently talking about was art
we want to be space aware like physical
space aware
and then people say yes but but
deep learning networks are also grammar
aware the grammar is there and it
reproduces the grammar
but it's it's grammar where in the same
way as ptolemy was
it was a relativity aware it reproduces
the correct predictions of relativity
theory without following me having a
clue
about the actual theory of relativity so
that's sort of the difference sort of
the it's not a theory sort of popping
out of your
of your statistical system your
statistical system reproduces
the predictions of theory but it's not
sort of aware of the theory
and and that's that's kind of a subtle
difference i say i mean awareness is
where
where where you
where you can actually make inferences
that's what we humans do like like we
make inferences because we
are aware of the physical space and what
you were just giving the example of like
uh start recording is exactly about this
awareness
like knowing that that yannick is there
in the studio and can push a button or
something like that
i'm really glad that you said what you
did for the last few minutes because
you know going back to like kind of the
academic stuff we talked about earlier
part of the problem is people have this
tendency to really want to find
silver bullets right like they want the
one true
method that will solve all their
problems and i think there's really if
if we step back and be objective about
it there's overwhelming evidence
throughout all of our history that there
are no silver bullets that things are
hybrid systems that require exactly
and so so if i'm hearing you correctly
you're not saying that
that this paradigm is the silver bullet
that's going to solve
all nlp and more importantly nlu natural
language understanding problems
but it's a very important tool in the
toolbox that happens to
very nicely map a part of the
mathematics of that domain to quantum
computing so we can get a very good
efficient implementation of a piece of
it
but we still may need to do other types
of computation
around on top of that mixed in with it
is that true
i mean of course like i mean i mean just
think about like
like uh cylindrical versus the versus
cartesian coordinates you know
i mean it's something like that right
like you know yeah
one is useful in one place one is
usually another place i mean i said it
earlier like the stylistic stuff machine
learning is really good at
well like emulating acts you're
emulating uh
picasso or something like that it's
incredibly good and like for example in
the linguistic context i'm talking about
that i mean would be stupid of us to try
to in any way emulate these abilities of
machine of deep learning like to
reproduce style that's why i'm so happy
with our new approach to grammar where
we actually get rid of style
so we say okay that's that's your domain
let's see now
if we can make the drill the real core
backbones
of grammatical interaction and i want to
say something more about it later
uh present are there things we can do
better that's the question
are there things we can do better and
and places where i think we can i think
we can be much more economical
we can be for certain applications we
can be much more economical because you
don't need to learn all the stuff
i mean if you can if you can take
something because you know it already
maybe doesn't work perfectly in all
contexts maybe you really need this
ambiguity in certain contexts but there
will be contexts where it's actually
good to have
to actually get that piece for free so
that you can focus on something else
uh same with the physical space maybe
there are contexts where it's much
better to try to learn the physical
space because the space is so up
but for for many contacts getting this
big
piece of information like like thank you
euclid like you did is all for us like
okay let's let's make use of it i mean
it's good to have it
i mean are you i mean just to get
another context like we have theories
of physics like relativity and quantum
mechanics are we now going to go to a
paradigm that we're going to forget
about them and say
oh no let's machine learning do all of
this again we'd be stupid we'd be stupid
yeah
so some people want to but no no i know
i know there are people who actually
believe that i know there are people who
believe that like
the problem is with these deep learning
models is they're they're a bit like a
parlor trick
they do a lot of things so in the
context of language processing they have
some
world knowledge for example they have
you are saying they have the illusion of
understanding
grammar they don't really they're just
probabilistic likelihood models they're
just predicting
the next word in a sequence so they're
extremely limited but they appear
on the surface to be doing very very
clever things right but but the
alternative is we
we take a step back and we start
explicitly and discreetly formalizing
grammar again
and then we get all the original
problems we had like janet you were
saying it's np
hard for doing the constituency
processing and doing the past trees and
all this kind of stuff right i know
the wrong grammar this is the
bureaucratically overloaded grammar the
complexity comes from the
bureaucratic overload so so all these
things have to be revisited again
so so now now to be no no it's not just
about
so so this is more important it's not
just about grammar i don't think this
grammar
is is something very specific to
language at all so because when we start
building our spatial model
uh basically that's a theory of spatial
relationships like how different things
can be related in space a priori this
has nothing to do with language
the priority because these just entities
in space and they have certain relations
but it this very naturally follows the
same sort of grammatical umbrella
it's very natural to give the same
grammatical umbrella we've got a paper
from a few years
ago it's called interacting conceptual
spaces and we play the same gale
game for uh garden force conceptual
spaces they
they obey very naturally the same
umbrella
for me the piece of grammar which
remains
maybe we should call it grammar maybe
it's it maybe it's kind of bad pr to
even call it grammar
whatever remains in the circuits it's
it's an interaction it's an interaction
structure in the world
so so just think of the of the k like
like you got to pray you got a predator
and you got to hunt
it's some sort of logical process you
know which so so
there is the process each takes it takes
in two things
a prey and a predator and there is a
goal so it's some sort of logical entity
and many many things if you in the world
have this sort of logical structure
and you can bring in more sort of
grammatical ideas they they will then
bring in like things like
if things have like adverbs and net
positions and things like that
they bring like higher order aspects of
that same process
but it doesn't have to do anything with
language per se
so what we're trying to retain is more
sort of a
structure of reality which i wouldn't
call it the logic because it has no
propositional
uh uh in the sort of uh
greek aristotle way type of deductive
power
it's really a way of fitting things
together in the world
and and the world the word i use
compositional of course
it's a way of fitting things in in a
rational way
together in the world and you can you
can come up with a model of physical
space
which follows that follows a template
it's built in in language
it's not a surprise because like our
granddaddies they were like trying to
get down the mammoth they were screaming
at each other so the language probably
developed
by their spatial sort of uh
considerations because if they didn't
communicate their spatial consideration
trying to get down the mammoth
the mammoth killed them all you know so
it's a it was a matter of surviving like
language emerged from like survival
i mean i mean it's it some really like
there are too many interesting things
here i
um going back to what you were saying
with some people want to go back and try
to do relativity
throw it out replace it with machine
learning i mean the absolute
madness of the world is that something
like relativity even exists right that
that someone can write down like one
formula it's like oh here
just do you know this uh this metric
tensor with the fourth dimension
negative and
boom it describes the entire world like
it describes
like the a wide range
and like the completeness almost of the
world
now my question to you is
do you think something like this is even
possible
for how messy human language is or
something like human language and second
what in your formalism or in your system
what is the required amount of human
input
like how much do you as a human have to
you know program let's say the structure
of the world
into the system for for it to be able to
then understand
the world so so about to your first
yoga language is a very messy thing so i
completely agree
uh so what what we are trying to dig out
is is
the non-messy part of it is there any
way we can identify a non-messy part and
like i said we already
threw away this bureaucracy which is
language dependent which is stylistic
dependent
and all these things and i think we got
we got rid of a lot of the sort of
noise of it a lot of the sort of
difficult stuff to really capture
like i said before i think part of the
reasons people who have been trying to
bring in grammar
into into sort of uh statistical uh
schemes i think they probably did
something wrong that they actually still
believed
that there was anything deductive going
on there because there's no way
structurally you can ever blend this
with a linear structure of a vector
space which is never going to work
and the second part is they took the
they also were bringing in all this
bureaucracy which was unnecessary
so i'm really talking so what i'm
talking about is really a new theory of
grammar i'm going to be
bloody arrogant here i think it's the
best thing in grammar that happens since
montague
and and i mean i'm super arrogant i i
believe this i've been telling this to
people
and and personally i'm working on this
think this is the biggest thing in
gramercy's montague
i mean i believe this i mean you're
writing it down we're having it down
it's a really big deal
and it's incredible if you look at the
pictures the amount of complexity that
comes in
by putting sting on things on the line
it's incredible
we did we can depict this incredible
complex network
just by trying to stick a single
sentence on the line how complex the
process is
uh on the second so that was the first
question so
so so the thing is that there is
something underneath
i think like relativity because it's
it's it's it's some sort of logic of
all the world words it's not language
language stakes that in language uses
that as a backbone
language is developed against that logic
so bringing that logic into language
will help understand language
and simplify the understanding of
language but it's not all of language
it's not language
so that's what i completely disagree
with montagu
and and and chomsky and all the urinal
ones that there is anything
special about the structure of grammar
with respect to humans but i'm now
talking about like uh
the distilled clean structure which
maybe we shouldn't call grammar but what
i'm still kind of calling grammar
there's language there's reality and
there's meaning right and i can
understand how this compositional
analysis could tell you something about
um let's say our language and maybe you
could use that as a proxy for reality in
some sense or there that's a bit of a
leap
but what about you know syntax isn't
semantics right isn't it isn't
isn't that the fundamental problem i
mean i never really i mean
in the way we're doing things that
separation doesn't really exist anymore
that much
because a lot of the of the stuff we put
in the
in the domain of of meaning actually is
is structure itself
so so that the in so so in in the old
fashioned way of doing grammar you
really had sort of you got the types and
then then you got sort of your your
your proof of correctness of the
sentence and all that
and it all lived outside of the meaning
of the words in
we have to dig inside the meaning of the
words and look at
internal wirings without within what
usually we
would call semantics to make it work to
actually get our circuits
there is enormous amount of structure
within the words
themselves within the semantics and it
seriously reduces the complexity of all
these things
because i mean why did the vector
back of words work so well for example
it took like an adjective
and a noun and a verb all in the same
space there are two arguments for them
on the first hand if you look at type
theoretic structure or something like
that you say this is absurd because
an adjective is something which changes
a noun into a different noun
it acts on a noun so expect it to be a
map but then again when you say
red like is making something red or a
lot of these
adjectives actually are kind of nouns in
content
so you actually have to go inside the
map of the adjective
stick this down in there and then do
some wiring
and so that actually makes everything
much more economical and that's sort of
part of
our old scheme that we go inside the
meanings and then do some
structure inside the meanings which sort
of then
uh kind of wires up with the with the
grammatical structure and
causes the incredible collapsing
complexity so the two come together
now there are i mean there are simple
things in english language like the way
we order adjectives
there is a clear structure on there so
so that there are the seven or eight
classes and we put it
and this again this is kind of relate i
see this as related
when i say the meaning space is sort of
factor in different substructures
some are about size some are about
shapes some are about curves
and these are really these factors which
come in
into the space of objective so that's
something we have to recognize
and again the order is what you could
call syntax because it sort of tells you
rules and how to order things
well it's connected but well what
defines where you live
are meanings another example are for
example prepositions most prepositions
have spatial connotation next above in
so they seem to make direct reference to
spatial structure
if you're ever going to do inferences
which involve prepositions
then you need to have some spatial
awareness so it is all mixed up these
all mixed up syntax and semantics
yeah there's a couple things that i kind
of want to talk about here so
i you know i think it's a bit uh you
know it's a bit of an optical illusion
to say that the complexity disappears
because what's happened is you've
replaced the complexity with
entanglement you know i mean so the
complexity is all there it's just in a
quantum mechanical
structure that you're kind of taking
advantage of and because one thing i
want to avoid is
you know in the beginning i started to
feel that you were not a reductionist
and i was happy about that because
you know you talked about togetherness
which to me is synonymous with at least
holism or emergence or this kind of
thing i mean
the meaning of a word by itself is
you know blatantly not sufficient to
define well i completely agree i
completely agree
so so i mean we are maintaining this
this complexity
the ensemble complexity if you will the
emergent
complexity yes being maintained for us
kind of you know for free although ibm
would probably disagree with that but
you know for free by quantum sort of
structures when i said the reduction of
the complexity in using your terminology
now
it's like think of think of the meanings
as some sort of holes
initially they're sort of we don't know
what they are they're the wittenstein
they're determined by their context to
to a great extent right they're all sort
of fixed
so what i'm talking about is the
complexity of the network that connects
them together
and which then allows you to sort of for
example
uh variationally learn from the context
what your meanings are
so it's the net the complexity of the
network around them which simplifies
that's it but it but that's that's
exactly that's
like i said that's exactly so it so the
way we got to it was actually by having
to put this stuff on a quantum computer
because the quantum computer forces
first to go two dimensional into a
circuit
and that this is a very interesting
story i think people may not realize
like
when you get a course on quantum
computing or quantum quantum mechanics
then they teach you like oh measurement
you can't get information out of your
system because if you measure you
disturb and you'll never get
it's impossible to sort of get the state
the state out of your quantum system
now it turns out in in present day
quantum computing it's incredibly
difficult to get your state inside the
machine too
it's not just getting it out it's
getting it in too and and
the quantum computing people who are
trying to do
relatively short-term stuff in chemistry
and all that the only solution they came
up with
to actually get something in a machine
is using basically learning
so so what you do is like you got some
network which is typically a circuit
like a quantum circuit
and then you got variables now these
variables are actually classical
variables in the sense of their gate
settings
their gate settings and then you
basically train
you train your circuit and you adjust
your gate settings and that's the only
efficient way at the moment people
can get uh data in a quantum computer so
it's
i don't think machine learning would
ever have the machine learners would
have thought
that they were actually coming up with a
paradigm
to actually get stuff into a quantum
machine i don't think they never talk
because you're not doing anything it's
purely for reasons of encoding your data
that you use learning so it's it's kind
of a funky thing
so now let me explain why so these
quantum computers
are are quite small at the moment like
you can't do much you can't go very deep
and and what people do now uh typically
is they take one of these circuits and
they kind of think of it as a neural
network
if you want to so it's just some network
some circuit with some gates and all
that
but typically they don't mean anything
it's just whatever works best
just like in typical learning you take
the structure of the network the layers
what
whatever work best whatever works best
but it's it's very hard to assign an
individual meaning to every node in your
network like like this is lsd's book it
doesn't work like that you know like
they're just nodes there
so our networks on the quantum computer
they
they represent like like the interact
the grammatical interactions and all
that between the different things
if you want the agents within the text
so they on the nose represent they are
meaningful
so that's where we get a big advantage
because these stick
you have to use them there's just no
other way to get your stuff into a
quantum computer but then using these
circuits but for us the circuits mean
something
for all the rest they mean they mean the
non-meaning part of language
if you know they're the channels in
which the meaning flows
there are channels in which the meaning
flows and then the like you say
the meanings of the word are learned by
twisting these
variables so we learn we learn the words
within the broader context
so they are literally learned within the
context of all the
of the entire bigger piece of
information you get so it completely
appeals to your holistic
view right sure we had no choice it was
not even like that we chose to do it
like that
we had the other choice right so the
entanglement is maintaining the
complexity i have a question about that
though which is that
do you i mean is it really the case that
the entanglement that so happens to be
quantum mechanics just happens to
exactly align
with the entanglement that we need for
natural language processing is that just
accidental it isn't me you picked vector
spaces there yeah i mean
people start to work with vector spaces
so i mean you're already very close if
you then
i think the composition the composition
the tensor structure is canonical that
comes like from from from the way
grammar and all that works that's that's
just canonical
that so the tensor product is canonical
so you got your vector spaces your
tensor product that's canonical
what is not canonical is that suddenly
there's complex numbers around
that that that doesn't come from
standard nlp practice
although i have seen that um there have
been some papers where people use
complex numbers in classical nlp to
extend parameter spaces
and also that there is some word by by
trio a french guy i think to your
or where where if you then start to
factor uh
entity and bearings and all like that
that to do this properly you actually
need complex numbers
purely for analytical reasons so they do
come in they do come in classical nlp
too but that's where the conceptual
justification is much less
that's where the conception but i mean i
mean let
s so okay so so one of the things i
don't understand like in the way um
and and you don't even have to think
quantumly you can think classical
classical probabilistically like if you
got two things like
let's just not talk let's talk
ideologically more about like how
scent our meanings should interact and
stuff like that if we work with
idealized mailings
so typically you got alice and bob and
then maybe alice and bob do something
but the way alice and bob are traded in
any vector and bearing is pretty much
on their own so you've got another's
vector and you got a bob vector
it doesn't make sense to me because
they've got a pre
they probably they didn't just come from
different planets and and found each
other there is like a prehistory which
connects them
and the way to connect that pre-history
like in classical probability is some
sort of collage correlations existing
between them
that's not all present in the way the
way people now do nlp now
why not it's probably very costly to do
that it's incredibly costly to do that
if you want to encode all these
correlations it i mean you get an
exponential blow up
and and that's that's some so but i
think it's natural to do that
it's natural to assume that your
different uh
actors in in whatever whether you plays
have some sort of
pre-existing correlations with each
other it's always like that
and and i mean so so uh
but that also tells me that that that
the whole idea of static meanings is
something we should go away from so so
the last
so so we we are very much thinking in
terms of not just like holistic meanings
but also dynamical meanings
that's cool i've got a paper called the
mathematical of the mathematics of text
structure which is from before
the sort of talk i mean this was
actually the start of trying to
turn grammar into into circuit-like
things with evolving meanings
uh and and it sort of then starts to
subsume the grammatical structure in
that paper already you see that some of
the complexity of uh
of your traditional grammatical calculus
is like
kind of vanishing it's it's it's it's
it's simply that
i mean you have to think you've got all
this stuff on the line so i mean
it is a funny thing like uh so a
collaborator of me like
like um vernon chad zadeh she she
analyzed like
uh the grammar in different languages
and how far away words are communicating
to each other in a single sentence
so you take huge sentences like in
english in english it's all kind of
efficient because the
english are all sort of very diplomatic
efficient people
if you go to something like persian then
you have words on one side of the
sentence like humongous sentence
which is informing a word on the other
side of the sentence
now like these distances in the circuit
they go away
they all vanish that's basically what
happens so
so so so in in a lot of traditional
gravity you've got this hopping from one
sentence to another very complex boom
boom
boom boom that all vanishes that's what
i mean by the complexity it's sort of a
much more efficient way of communicating
between the words in in in a sentence if
you just put them in a plane
that's what i mean but but all the rest
stays the same you know like
you can think of your words as holes and
it's just the network which which which
which glues them together which becomes
much simpler
that that's essential so it's a
different notion of complexity
if you're talking about complexity of
representing the meanings of course the
entanglements are gonna
just like i was saying like oops that's
too much and action they were sort of uh
the entanglements are gonna be humongous
they're they're not they're
exponentially huge
they're not maintainable on a classical
machine it's it's as simple as that
i mean there's probably lots of way ten
tens of contraction tricks and and
all the sort of modern stuff dealing
with cancer which will help you a lot
with that
we have we haven't we haven't really
gone enough in it's something we so i'm
actually i actually really started to
build up this team
only a year a year and a half ago and
and now we're starting to look properly
in all these things with like a
dedicated team in the industry and like
steve clark i mean he has a lot of
experience in practical nlp by working
many years
i mean he has done his whole life like
practical nlp so it's good to have
somebody like that on board but he's
also like a
belief in the stuff we are doing you
have an algorithm to translate all of
english
into this kind of circuitry yeah now
could you could you just describe a bit
how that algorithm works and is the
algorithm for
let's say grammatically correct english
or is the algorithm
with the algorithm parsing for something
like hey what's up
this is still in the in the idealized
realm at this point this is still in the
idealized realm
so so basically what you do i kind of
sort of hinted that before
so we got this picture i mean i control
our typical pictures of languages you
got like the meanings
words they are sort of boxes meanings
are books and then they're wired
together
with grammar so you actually have to go
inside the boxes
and put some wirings in there too so
i mean for for certain words like
relative pronouns these are just like a
bunch of wires and
for many functional words these are just
wires if you go to things which actually
have content like a verb or
then you've got a little box in the big
box and then also a lot of wires
these wires they're very they're all you
can they're all very justified we even
have
theorems that with the right
representations they come at no cost
so if you stick them inside and then let
these wires interact with the
grammatical structure solely everything
collapses into something much more
but that is something it's a magical
thing it's a magical thing
you have to know okay the word
it's exactly like you were talking about
montague you just need to know the type
well the meaning but you you need like
you need to your compiler needs to have
a list of saying
you need you need some ccg parser or
something like that yeah yeah okay
now at this point here's the here's the
maybe the heretic
question could we learn
these types
yeah ultimately you want to ultimately
you want to uh
well but i mean we we're working in sub
steps now like we
we actually got it's kind of really cool
tool we've got like uh
whether you believe in what we do or not
it's really cool you can type in
whatever sentence and then it
spits out a quantum circuit you can
actually i mean i don't think we've
provided the link but we've got it
working
it's kind of cool it's kind of cool
anyway
it's funky but yeah i mean you need
so so so the question is if you don't
know the
so there's actually there's like this
one paper i know by uh
smolansky and some some some microsoft
people who actually use actually also
quantum computer to come up with the
parsing
like just like you were saying they come
up with a probabilistic tree of what is
the likely parsings here and there
and they can then of course deal with
stuff which is not entirely grammatical
so but they still use smallansky's model
they still use molansky's model which is
way too complicated
so um bob you you wrote a 900 page book
on
i think it's called um picturing quantum
processors right and and
you've been working on this formalism
actually this pictorial formalism or
calculus or quantum reasoning
i think you said since about 2004 and
i've actually read your new book which
is aimed at
high school students i know you've got
an idea actually that it might be
possible to democratize quantum
reasoning to the point that
school kids can actually do it and and i
and i read through it and it was
actually understandable
even to me so um how did this all come
about
i mean i mean so i'm he's part of my
brain
uh and and and when we had to read a
book at school just reading a book at
school
i mean i hated it i just always hated to
read it it basically gave me an edit
i think there may be something to do
with my missing part of my brain or
whatever but i just hate reading i
always hated reading
uh and then i mean the the idea to have
like some some black print on white
paper and that's supposed to convey
something to you i've always thought it
was completely absurd
uh so i'm very visual person uh i mean
yeah i mean um
so also mathematically i think i've
always thought very geometrically
there's no way i mean i i don't
understand i can't stare at symbols so
that's that's something very personal i
know there's probably
some people are sort of more
symbolically brightly minded otherwise
are more others are more geometrically
minded
but in my case it seems to be pretty
extreme now now the reason i got there
was a
basically uh my hatred of quantum
mechanics i just i just thought the
quantum formalism there is something
fundamentally wrong with
and then one of the places it seemed to
me was this idea
that that that what's more important
than anything about quantum mechanics is
the way systems interact it's actually
something i learned in hindsight that's
schroedinger had set in the thirties and
nobody had turkey
took attention from so so so basically
the key so for neumann always start what
is what what is the most important thing
about quantum mechanics i mean i got the
microphone here
it's like you start observing the
microphone and and and
what it does i mean observe the
microphone would for example be speaking
into it
and stuff like that you know it's kind
of quite the knowledges and then inside
something starts vibrating
so that that was the deployments idea
you interact with the system and then
it came actually up with something which
is called quantum logic like what are
sort of propositions we can attribute to
that
and then this propositional structure is
completely different from a boolean
algebra it turns out
uh so sharing i said no it's not that
it's like what happens if i put the
microphone next to the speaker
so i put the two together
[Music]
it doesn't care what happens inside the
microphone it doesn't care what this
happens in either side of the speaker
what he cares about is if i put the two
together suddenly i get like the sound
circus you know
a new phenomena emerges which was
impossible to have with the microphone
alone and which was impossible to have
in the speaker alone
yeah and it's the same thing in
intelligence i mean i'm fascinated by
embodied intelligence and
you know kind of like
self-referentiality and the the the
emergence of of these kind of complex
dynamical systems as a function of their
interaction
the thing the thing mathematical
formalisms throughout the i mean
they never actually focused on this sort
of thing they always start from
you describe well i mean you you take a
set with structure and then you you
build your hilbert space and then maybe
take a tensor product for two yellow
spaces
but you don't start discussing the
interaction without actually you have to
know already that you're dealing with
human space before
and this thing is not a hill display as
a microphone and the speaker is not a
hybrid spacer
what is how is there some match which
connects them without having to say
what they actually are and that's
actually so the place where i started
was category theory and specifically
tensor monoidal categories because
that's where you can do that
i mean category theory books are the
most horrible things to actually
understand and that's what that's what
it's supposed to describe it's just
horrible
it doesn't tell you that but that's it
but then at the same time for certain
kind of categories
certain kind of normal categories you
can show that they're completely
equivalent to
purely diagrammatic representation so
you first go very abstract
and then you then then you end up with
something which is so pure
that actually becomes very simple and
then the idea mathematically
of putting the microphone and the
speaker together is basically just
drawing two lines side by side one line
is the live line of the microphone
the other line is the live line of the
speaker and then
the sort of structure of the stuff you
can do before and after determines then
that that you can have this feedback
loop
and in in a cartesian work world where
things wouldn't interact at all like two
to two completely non-interacting things
then these wires will never come
together they will always stay separate
but in in a world where you got maximal
interaction like in quantum mechanics or
in language
you can actually f cup shapes between
these two wires like
probably reading reading the book like
these cup shaped things and then
if you look at lombic pre-group cx is
that he has exactly the same things the
cups and the caps and that's that's just
basically because words in this
church in a sentence they communicate
with each other within the sentence of
course otherwise you wouldn't form a
sentence if they were completely
independent
there's no point forming a sentence so
and there is nothing mystical about
the fact that these two structures occur
say language and in quantum
because from if you understand them like
mathematically they basically say this
is maximal communication
they're just the maximal mode of comp
communication while
cutting them apart would be the minimal
mode of communication
there's just maximal mode of
communication there's nothing more to it
today there's nothing mystical about
language there's some connection with
nothing nothing there's nothing there
so yeah i mean i mean the insight to
work with these diagrams was exactly the
same insight to work with the right
categorical structure
it they came hand in hand too it was
just an accident that they happened to
be diagrams
and and then at the time that was 2004
2005 it seemed like a
a nice sight a nice project in itself to
turn all of quantum mechanics
diagrammatically
it sort of showed up as an opportunity
by trying to eximatize
so so the real goal for me was trying to
have an holistic
because the word was holistic
presentation of quantum mechanics
through category theory and that ended
up becoming a diagrammatic formalism
i i think it's fascinating because i'm a
big believer in
creating powerful abstractions and
interfaces and being able to reduce
things to building blocks that
hide away a lot of unnecessarily um
complexity behind the interface and
that's what you've done
we see this in deep learning i mean we
had francois charles on the other week
he's created
keras which is a deep learning library
that completely abstracts away a lot of
the complexities of deep learning and
and i think actually your zx calculus
will democratize quantum reasoning for a
whole new generation of folks that
wouldn't be able to do it otherwise so
that that's great
um we've only got a few minutes left and
i just wanted to touch on
um the state of quantum hardware in
general now i i know that you've just
been appointed chief scientist um
at cambridge quantum computing and
can you just completely break this down
for us because there's so much hype and
misinformation around quantum computing
and certainly at my workplace we've got
loads of people that are doing quantum
computing and everyone's talking about
quantum computing and
and i've honestly i've just pretty much
ignored it i've filtered it out for
years because i i don't even know
what the state of the art is so can can
you like just tell us in clear terms
i mean the best way to tell it is i mean
i'm not going to do like the sort of the
context kind of thing
so in 2016 2017
uh when we were dealing with this
language formalism and
and the problem we had with the
exponential size of the tensors all that
i wrote a paper with a guy called
winsang
and and we said okay well let's see
which algorithms we can use if we stick
on a quantum computer
but i mean we i thought it was a joke
i thought this would never ever be
possible to even get anything like that
running on a quantum computer anywhere
in the next 10 years
so uh so what we have done
in the last sort of experiments is we
are training these these these these
these circuits with libraries of like
100 250 sentences
i mean they're they're quite complex
sentences
and then we do some sort of uh live
question answering and we get a very
nice convergences
but it's it's shocking that we can
actually do that
it's shocking that we can do this now i
mean there's of course no way that we
compete with anything existing
but for me it's shocking that we even
can do it
uh again from like an nlp perspective
the thing which google did
with their 53 qubits is something that
purely in terms of space requirements
like
representational space requirements you
couldn't do in a classical machine
there's no computer infrastructures
around in the world
which would allow to store the same data
so we're already at the level that we
that you can actually store more data in
such a machine i mean with all the
things that you can't exist and blah
blah blah blah but you can store more
data now in in a 53 quantum computer
then you can then you can do in an
existing computing system
but not stored it's not that you stick
it in but it is there
i mean there is stuff in there that you
can't
so if you understand so that so it it
already stretching beyond what's
possible classical in some way
and this has gone incredibly fast much
faster than
i mean i definitely imagine that many
people imagine and and
so the so the sort of chat has changed
from
is it going to happen to when it's going
to happen and i think most nobody even
the skepticals
in the field are starting to think that
it will not happen within 10 years
so let me just challenge a couple things
on that because you know my
my coffee cup here stores more
information than any current quantum
computer
right so so information isn't
necessarily
useful like in and of itself this is why
for example
there's only a handful of what 20
quantum mechanics algorithms right
because you
you know the algorithms themselves have
to fit in a form
that's actually usable on a quantum
computer so i think
i mean i think you would agree we're
still in the so-called uh
nisk era right like the noisy
intermediate totally i mean okay i mean
totally totally i mean what i mean i
didn't make any claim about predictions
you know
right i was very careful not to do that
and i was just i'm just
showing my surprise and how quickly it
has gone and the fact that
we have been able to do what we are
doing already on such a machine i'm
completely in shock
okay but i'm not i'm not i'm not making
any projections and i'm
saying now that the general attitude
i think within the community including
the skepticals
is now that in around 10 years you will
have something practical
okay although the the hype currently
says it's less i wouldn't dare sort of
to put the number on it like
i mean i mean if you really would force
me i think we can do something in two
three years
that's meaningful so just specifically
for the language
i think we can do something in two three
years that's meaningful
that you couldn't do on a classical
machine okay that's
by no means necessarily
something you can sell okay so fair
enough
on the other hand it would just be more
a proof of concept
yeah i mean and fair enough but i think
part of that is due to if i recall from
one of your papers
part of that optimism is due to the fact
that you were able to map some specific
nlp problems to problems that could
still function
in a nisk like in a non-error-corrected
quantum computer is that correct
uh yeah yeah yeah i mean i mean i mean
the results are pretty okay but the
results are like competitive
comparatively
with a small scale experiment on
classical hardware
if you would do really clear small scale
experiment like the the data is
is clean enough it's it's it's it's
equally clean more or less
so so sure i just wanted to see if you
agree that because
this probably has to do with the fact
that nlp is noisy anyway
right so i think i just wanted to make
sure that that
you agree because hype in and of itself
can be a dangerous thing it can lead
people down
you know waste avenues so i mean yeah i
mean you know
we started this conversation with hype
about well and hype about string theory
and then the same hype here
because and quantum computing like the
meaning of it has kind of changed over
the years like
in the early days what quantum computing
meant to theoreticians was error
corrected computing like fault
fault free or or what not uh computing
and because we haven't gotten to there
yet right and we're still in the noisy
era
it's now morphed into well it also
includes you know non-error-corrected
quantum computing and i think like the
10-year timeline
for error-corrected practically useful
quantum computing
is not correct like we you know it's
even not clear
can you do it with a million qubits or
do you need you know 100 million qubits
before you can start having effective
you know error corrected quantum
computing is that fair or am i wrong
about that well i mean i mean
it it's very hard i mean let me start
with a negative example
like fusion nuclear fusion
i mean i remember when i was i mean
probably every single physics student
since since since the second world war
as has gotten lectures about like in
five ten years there will be nuclear
fusion reactors and they're clean and
then blah blah blah blah blah i got that
lecture in the
early nineties in five ten years we've
got fusion they're still not here
so so these are things like engineering
stuff like that is completely impossible
to to
predict now the situation with quantum
computer is much more complicated
because of the different architectures
which each have their own different
problems and advantages
so so so if you look at the
superconducting stuff which has been
getting most of the attention recently
because that's what google and ibm
and righty the superconducting stuff uh
i mean they're making good progress uh
they're making remarkably good progress
but there it's a lot of dealing
the noise dealings are really hard and
the sort of error correction seems
pretty far still then then you got for
example the the iron traps
these things are actually quite clean
themselves
you can go pretty deep with them they
have a harder time
putting uh many cubits together but like
i mean
i mean i've been talking quite a bit to
the imq guy and they're thinking they've
got a 100 cubit machine going
now 100 cubit machine if it's relatively
clean and you don't have to do error
correction
it's a pretty amazing thing this would
be a pretty amazing thing
now when we're talking about fault
tolerance and millions now we're talking
optics
because i mean optics light is is kind
of
freely available everywhere you know and
light is incredibly stable if it wasn't
stable we wouldn't be watching each
other now
it's pretty amazing how nice behaved
light is so i mean i know i know the psy
quantum guys like who get most of the
money
uh uh the the that they
they claim they're gonna have something
within four or five years i mean
i the guy i know is not like uh a
bragger
but he's but
and the sort of system they use is
completely different in architecture
from anything like the
ibm's and so they are doing measurement
based quantum computing
so measuring based quantum computing is
amazingly cool thing in itself
where you don't apply unit trees or you
don't apply operations you just measure
you do nothing else about measuring
and the the measurement dynamics
actually is what your computation
so that's what they're doing there's
completely different architecture which
has nothing anything to
anymore to do with any kind of computing
this is gonna work we don't know
but so so you got a few you've got a few
tracks here you've got a few tracks
so that's that's the difference with the
fusion where you're only at one track
so it could be that two two out of three
completely fail
but no i mean there's new tracks coming
by the way it's not just these three
there's a few other
so it's very hard to put put your money
anywhere because of these different
architecture which are completely
different
i mean maybe maybe and i think the smart
people they don't
i mean for a long time people who aren't
really looking for a quantum computer as
in a universal computer but quant
certain quantum components
and they could actually come from the
different machines together you know you
could have like this big hybrid thing
wherever you take a little bit
iron trap a little bit condensed better
a little bit like optics
uh yeah so it's it's a very hard one to
put any money on
it's a very hard one but but there is
something like self-fulfilling prophecy
and to this i mean let me say two things
about the hype there is something like
about
self-fulfilling prophecy by like putting
enough money into it this happened
in it for to give a bad well it depends
whether you call it a bad example it
happened to be the manhattan project
just i mean i think you you start your
story with the second world war and uh
why academia can in the u.s change so
much it was probably because of the
manhattan project
that they say if we can if we can sort
of make all these academics work on one
thing together to actually get it done
which is what happened then like the
guys you know category theory was
invented by two guys working on the
manhattan project
in the evenings they were doing that
they were there working on it didn't
know that yeah
so so so yeah and the the other thing so
there is this self-fulfilling prophecy
thing you know
the enormous amount of focus that's
going into it and the pressures
the pressures from the hype can actually
be the pressures on the hype can be
helpful too because there is this
pressure we have
we have to deliver because there is this
type i'm glad that in a way i'm glad
there is because we've spoken about the
hardware lottery on this channel quite a
lot
and that is almost all of the scientific
effort at the moment is determined by
the previous
investment and hardware decisions we've
made in the past we got a bit lucky with
the gpus and deep learning and so on but
we are in a basin of attraction in our
research
and there's hardly any interesting new
paths being taken
yeah so one another thing which i think
is different from
it's probably the same with machine
learning that was different from like
say string theory
which we're eating all theoretical
physics shops is that
most of the quantum stuff is happening
outside academia with investment and
money
which is complementary to the usual
academic funding so it's it's it's not
going to sort of eat away the other
disciplines
most people just leave academia because
the circumstances now to work and
quantum are better outside academia than
inside
it's as simple as that and then the
money comes from completely different
sources of course
yeah saving deep learning yeah it's
that's what i'm saying it's probably
analogous there
so i really don't and why they're hiring
so many machine learning faculty because
i mean it's almost seems to me that the
real good machine learning people
given the salaries outside and the
relative freedom
why would they stay in academia yeah
well we spoke to a guy called mark
serafin recently and he wrote a blog
post called the the great stagnation and
machine learning but he was saying that
machine learning people
now are a bit like the previous catholic
high priests or something like that that
they don't have to risk anything
they can go and earn a six-figure salary
they're just satisfacing and just you
know reeling out the same old stuff and
um you know it's almost like zero risk
yeah yeah anyway um professor
bob kirk thank you so much it's been an
absolute honor that you've joined us
this evening and
i really really appreciate it thank you
oh bro you got to go you got to get on
the crypto bro
why is uh did bitcoin do something today
or are we
no just the last few weeks i guess
what's happened to back up to like uh
you know enormous
above where it was before enormously
high and
enormous as in 50 000 or more than that
yeah and ether has made quite quite a
thing i mean they're doing really cool
stuff with ethereum like there's the
i don't know if the berlin upgrade has
already happened or is happening soon
but um
they're like really pushing stuff
forward
there's like new math coming out of
these communities it's it's pretty cool
wow so is it something that we should be
paying attention to
right i don't know if it's from yannick
i'll i'll
pay attention well if it not i i don't
think it has a big connection to
to ml per se uh because
i mean the technology itself is almost
orthogonal right
like there it's either it's it's like
super duper binary
like either your key fits or it doesn't
either
you know your proofs are correct or not
and
if not then it's infinitely bad there
there's no notion of
closeness or anything um
yeah i mean there there is there is
these topics of how can we
do machine learning on blockchain and so
on but that's a
it's a bit of a tangent would it be
beneficial to have a couple of qubits
i can give you one oh have we got one
keith hmm
well i'm just thinking we could if i
gave you a q bit could you give me
some ethereum a cubit
yeah you can actually a physical qubit
yeah
how large is it i'm going to give you a
quantum computer
yeah and you can have one of my qubits
would that be enough for you
i i wouldn't even know how to remotely
use that
well i don't understand the question
yeah are you asking if i would pay you
for your qubits you would like to start
mining
ethereum yeah and what if i gave you a
quantum computer
i think that would break it i think so
most of the
crypto technology today isn't actually
quantum proof
in there in their hashing but
as soon as quantum computers are on the
market they'll just switch to a quantum
proof algorithm so
it wouldn't actually do anything yeah
it'll just it might just make them
wherever they can go back and uh troll
all your old uh emails that have been
stored in nsa or whatever even if you've
encrypted them and
find out what you said and you know i
guess they'd have to upgrade the
blockchain they'd have to go back and
re-encrypt it and get everybody to
switch over to a new chain
so i'm in a startup now my own actually
it sucks it means that whenever i make a
mistake
we go bankrupt it means that you're no
longer welcome on street talk janet
because we we don't we don't do startups
picture yeah i'll start trying to pitch
your start up
yeah no nba speak if if you say anything
about data products then you'll be
banned
no we just want to make the world a
better place of course of course
here's what you do put make sure you put
don't be evil
in your corporate you know mission and
then 10 years from now take it out
so so kilter will give you this one
opportunity give us the elevator pitch
you've got 30 seconds uh
what do your numbers look like for year
three um
we you 20 seconds
um uh
we use transformers of course you do
okay good good start i hope so you want
to buy it
any any blockchain in there no does it
solve the missing text problem
it yes yes it is is it illegal
is it the legal software yes yeah it's
illegal it's just it's legal tech
and uh yeah it's i think it's pretty
straightforward application of sort of
legal and uh like nlp to legal
is it information retrieval yeah it's
it's some is information retrieval yes
but but there's there's lots of tasks
and
um there's lots of competition but i
think you know in switzerland and in the
german speaking part we sort of have a
home field event okay so this is the
debrief
we've just had a great show with bob
what what what do you guys think about
that
i gotta tell you so this is such a great
example at least for
for me of how dialogue and just talking
to somebody
just brings a completely different
understanding of their work
because before you know and
i can't explain it but i mean before
actually having a chance to talk with
them listen with them interact
you know with bob it was like i really
came across thinking
this is a reductionist sort of silver
bullet kind of you know
theory for how like everything is going
to be solved by this particular
quantum mechanical you know formulation
of nlp and he's not
he's that's not his point at all so so i
mean
yeah i think this is an example of how
things like you know you know how on the
internet if you're in a forum or
something or an email chain things can
spiral like
out of control so quickly and so it's
just an example of how this
iterative dialogue back and forth is
such an important
you know communication mechanism i wish
we saw a lot more of it
personally um you know maybe
viewers here don't don't they don't know
this but
i at some point i looked at discord and
there were over
like my notification counter was over
with people like sending back and forth
papers and
and were like and
yeah i felt the same thing like once you
you talk to someone
and you you let them you let them talk
let them actually explain themselves and
and
also challenge them a bit on on on just
your
let's say if you have some worries if
you have some concerns about if or
you know you just put that to them and
give them a chance to
to express that and i i think
we've yeah we've almost never gone wrong
doing that
and it's i think that makes
makes the world much more interesting
because
actually a lot of people seem to be much
more reasonable
and kind of down to earth and
understanding than it would seem from
just
reading about them yeah no nuance is so
important
i was quite worried about this show for
a few reasons because first of all it's
definitely outside of our comfort zone i
mean i don't really know anything about
quantum and
and bob is such a strange beast he is um
invoking many formalisms and approaches
from
computational linguistics that we
haven't really seen for a very long time
a huge overlap with warleads and he saw
the path that he traveled
like the path that he traveled to get to
where he's at very you know eclectic
completely different i i love that
because he actually said he's an oxford
professor and he's admitting that he's a
very visual thinker
and he likes to think about problems in
a different way he's written a book
about quantum reasoning
for high school students and i read that
book the other day and i'll do some
stuff about it in in the intro but
it's just so fascinating for me just to
see the diversity
and also us to be out of our comfort
zone because you know
as charlay said information it's the
intelligence is the information
conversion ratio and
and we're putting ourselves out there by
you know challenging ourselves with a
lot of material that we've not seen
before and then
i i was a bit i was a bit worried
actually because
i thought that we would be challenging
him on things like syntax
not semantics and the missing
information problem
and i i personally don't believe
strongly that
his nlp system works particularly well
quantum or not and we challenged him on
that and and
i i thought we had a great exchange yeah
i mean i don't i don't think
personally i don't think we should ever
be afraid of i mean i know
i know what happens right because people
come into the comments and whatever else
i mean
we're in my opinion we're here to be you
know hosts we're here to ask
questions whether they're dumb or not
you know whether i don't care
like i'm not pretending to be somebody
who knows
everything the expert on the show knows
i mean what would be the point of that
you know just having a you know we want
to bring people along for a journey and
kind of represent questions
and evoke conversation to challenge
where we're capable
i mean that's how i view our our role so
i'm not afraid to
to be put myself out there and be deemed
you know an idiot like that that's fine
i don't mind the explicit goal on any
episode i don't i don't even have i
don't even have to do anything
differently for
to evoke that so you like mark twain
right like better to be thoughtful than
to open your mouth and remove all doubt
the only thing we need to be evoking is
as many cop
comments from walid sabra as possible i
i think this will generate at least
three
so so the the the important thing for me
as well is
and you're saying that like getting out
of our comfort zone and i think
getting sort of the mainstream
which is by definition the largest
portion of people
out of their comfort zone because if you
look at
nlp today and you go on i don't know
youtube and
and all blogs and reddit and so on it's
whatever transformers transformers
transformers transformers maybe some
graph neural networks maybe some lstm
transformers transformers certainly
certainly some kind of neural network in
there certainly
a big data set and scale and gpt3
it is absolutely refreshing to see
people doing completely different things
and and and not saying that
they're gonna replace neural networks
like that that's
like that is like the biggest credit to
let's say him or also people like like
wally tsaba who who we had on
but just saying like look there's stuff
missing and no one's
talking about it and you know we're here
even though it's not popular we're here
actually doing that stuff that's missing
and charlay's in the same boat yeah
right yeah yeah exactly
so that's i i think that's that's super
super cool agreed yeah well
there you go putting ourselves out of
our comfort zone because we could just
make a video about
um a kaggle competition or yeah
boring yeah yeah i mean that stuff so so
i i don't i don't know i i hope
i hope our uh listeners appreciate that
that we do this because look
honestly i'm out there trying to have
fun i'm out there trying to learn
i'm out there to to try and bring along
some other folks that that want to have
fun and learn and you know this is this
is a very fun thing to do
like have challenging conversations to
ask questions what's more fun than
asking a question
and learning something you know um you
know uh jose
capablanco like the you know sort of
chess genius who was world champion
for i don't know like 15 years or
something absurd
i mean just a natural-born chess talent
and then started very early playing and
became this phenomenal
you know force and his in his biography
he wrote that one of the darkest times
of his professional career
was when he felt like he would never
lose another game because he went
through the streak where he just never
lost it was just draw
win draw a win right and uh you know he
he said he learned so much from every
game that he lost
that he just was dismayed that he was in
this situation where he's never going to
have that experience of
of learning again and that's what i i
love to learn and
ask questions i don't i don't know the
answer to i mean that's the fun part
isn't it well it's scary like today
you know i mean who yeah you know say
quantum computers i mean if you're not
in that field i don't know how you could
possibly keep up with
with what's happening technologically
because it's just
exploding there's so much hype there's
so much stuff going on
and it was really cool to hear from
about these different you know uh
types of quantum computers because
honestly the only ones i had ever really
paid attention to or saw kind of
theoretical results were all about the
you know electron spin yeah uh quantum
acu
computers and so when he told me about
this light based
you know quantum computer that
fascinates me because going back to when
i was a kid
you know we used to to read scientific
american articles or discover articles
or whatever about
optical computing and everybody's like
oh optical computing it's gonna just
you know and you look in in science
fiction movies and they've got these
optical chips and everything like in
2001 you know they're plugging in little
clear crystal uh cylinders and you know
things
like that it's just cool right so now i
want to go read about
optical quantum computing and daydream
about a world where we're where we've
got machines like that
right so that's the fun part yeah the
hype around quantum is a serious problem
i that's why i've just learned to filter
it out
because normally when i'm reading
articles or
people sharing stuff on linkedin or it's
it's just
surrounded by a smoky hype and i just
don't know what the state of the art
is says the ai consultant
well i i like to think that we are quite
good at cutting through the
here on street talk we
we challenge ourselves a lot
i think yeah i think we do um i'm the
first to say that
um there's a lot of hype around deep
learning no
honestly i think the chalet episode was
the most concise
articulation yet of my opinion on on
the state of deep learning i think deep
learning is
a wonderful pattern matching system
for learning these continuous natural
manifolds
and what's amazing is that some of it
isn't
hype deep learning really has been a
revolution right
i mean just just just imagine that again
you know like interpolating between
people's faces that don't exist it's
that's incredible
but yeah no it it completely is
what i push back against are the silver
bullet people like that
we've got to understand folks that
there's no one true solution to
everything
know that the amazing and bizarre thing
about reality is that it has
you know these theories and models kind
of on multiple
levels you know whether whether you
think about it as theories that emerge
or if you're a reductionist and you want
to say you can always break things down
to a finer level that's still the same
dimension which is that there are
multiple levels of
of operation and thought and and theory
and
and method right and so forget about
silver bullets
they're not out there okay like you know
deep learning machine learning
fantastic for some problem space it's
not the solution to all our problems
deep learning is uniquely deceptive
and that's because it's a pile of trick
so you can use deep learning for
anything
you can make it pretend to be good at
even reasoning any kind of software as
as charlie was saying you you can even
model a continuous manifold around a
discrete problem
so it's uniquely deceptive because you
could say well i'm going to use this to
do some some reasoning and and it
appears to work
at first sight it appears to work and
that's why it's so deceptive
i can tell yannick is thinking exactly
like
well and while he's thinking i'm going
to say this which is i think a lot of
the deception
comes from um comes from the fact that
you have
sort of theories like you know that uh
that rel use are a universal function
approximator
right or that this sort of thing and
people forget about the infinities
that are kind of involved in those those
sorts of theories right and so
when you forget about infinity uh like
like james had this funny
funny thing where he did this uh this
analysis of um
of uh paradoxes and any and he
said you know some people define paradox
as something that's surprising to
somebody well then anything can be a
paradox right
and he actually goes so far as to
construct a paradox generator
and the way that you do it is you set up
a problem okay that that depends on a
limit like it depends on the way in
which you go to infinity
okay you take the limit and then you
forget
which limit you applied um and then
derive some results
right so it's like anytime you're kind
of taking these limits to infinity and
you forget that you've done that
then you get your mind into into these
weird situations yeah so people
people get deceived by these these
results that come from infinity
and then kind of forgetting about it and
not understanding that in a practical
scenario different tools work work well
in different situations are you talking
about touring completeness on neural
networks by any chance
that was no it's like not today i'm not
wasn't
that schmidt uber in his talk saying
like lstms are
like the most powerful thing because
they're touring complete and i
i made the point that so are crabs
because people built these logic gates
out of crabs
yeah what was that what was his example
well you can build an and gate and then
gate can build a cpu
and the cpu is turing complete right
yeah but the cpu is not turning complete
yeah it's only the it's only the fsm
piece of a turing complete
system right because you've got to have
and again no practical machine
is during complete but this is not not
the point
you know the you know the cpu also has
read write memory
so it has tapes and it has a thing which
is driving it in this iterative
you know process so like with with rnn's
you know always like oh they're turning
complete
here's the thing is as far as i know you
guys correct me if i'm wrong
nobody takes like every time you run an
rnn
you run it in an unrolled way and you
train it in an unrolled way which is you
have a finite look back
it's like i'm going to iterate but only
for some finite number of times and then
that's the
score for that sort of set of data which
is a time
series over a finite period of time
right like nobody runs an rnn where they
just sit there and
run it forever on a potentially infinite
you know input
and certainly nobody ever trains them in
that way am i wrong
well no no like practically you're not
wrong there
are there are things like neural odes
and
and stuff like this where you're you're
trying to sort of predict what happens
in in the limit or or at least after
some continuous
amount of time and things but yeah of
course you're right in a
like in the practical setting yeah okay
yes i mean sure
if you have an rnn and you're going to
iterate it for a
for a arbitrary amount of time a
potentially you know infinite amount of
time
and you supply it with some source of
potentially infinite memory
like whether it's tapes that it can
write to
or potentially infinite registers that
it can effectively treat as stacks or
whatever
then you've just got a turing machine
right you just have a turing machine
where the finite state machine piece the
transition function
is an rnn like so what like no like
that's not the point the point is that
rnns as people
in this field typically envision them
right
instead of redefining it as a as
essentially a turing machine
rnns as they typically envision them are
not turning complete
like it's just that simple i mean you
know we it'd be like if back in the day
you know when people were working on on
finite state machines
and before they introduced push down
automata
somebody just came along and go oh well
you know finite state machines are no
different than push down automata
because i can just
i can just like have an infinite number
of of nodes
in my finite state machine where i can
like add i can add a stack to it too
with like
infinite precision registers it's just
stupid you know i mean
the point is to create categories of
computation
to start to think about how they're
different how
you might train them you know et cetera
not to just say everything is everything
yeah like that doesn't
it's not you i think it's a trap to
think of neural networks as being
computers
i i think it makes much more sense as
chorley says just to think of them as
statistical interpolators stop thinking
that gbt3 is running a program
you know it's not well with i think with
with respect
the maybe the last thing i'll say but
with respect to deep learning be it
being a parlor trick
and whatnot i think i think you can like
i i'd weigh this with 90
uh of being true and the other 10
i think we have to we have to move from
from the other direction where i think
the perception is too much that
things like logic and understanding and
you know what we do as humans in our
head is
is so abstract and and is so symbolic
and
and all and i i think we also have to
move a bit away
from that to a point where where you say
i don't actually really know how my
thoughts
come to be i don't i don't actually do
the step-by-step inference all the time
i i actually sort of more you know do
whatever right and and and and that
is still called intelligence that is
still called
solving a problem or or transmitting
information and whatnot so
maybe for the the last 10 we also have
to admit that
we as humans aren't
aren't as are also a bit of a parlor
trick
sometimes and we're still yeah it's just
that they're
saying that deep learning is a bit of a
parlor trick it doesn't really
run an algorithm it doesn't really uh um
you know do some do the kind of
computation we
we as like the someone a deep mind might
demonstrate it does and so on
uh i just think that we
as humans probably don't do that
either some of the time and it's still
still we call it intelligence right
still i i agree with you on that and i
mean
and that's why i know in one of our one
of our shows we did i
you know we were talking to somebody and
i was asking like okay well what's
missing
right from from from neural net like
what is it that's in our brain that if
we just added this
to sort of computational neurons and
whatnot that we could now capture like
whatever's
and i think that's a useful paradigm to
think about which is let's start from
the assumption that
there's no magic there and that and that
whether it's a parlor trick or not
you know i don't know but the point is
to compare
like what's different about what we're
doing in this system versus this system
whether you're comparing a
an rnn to what a turing machine does or
an uh or a turing machine to a human
being or an rnn to a human being
like let's look for where the
differences are and that's what allows
us to
analytically break down what the
differences are and then turn around and
synthesize you know new systems and new
models that have different capabilities
um so i you know i completely agree with
that
there you go yeah and i think a lot of
it comes down to the dichotomy
between discrete and continuous
yeah that bizarre it comes up so many
places right like topology's weird
because it's both continuous and
discrete
you know you have these you sort of
think like a like a a doughnut or two
doughnut rings stuck together they
clearly have
two holes and that's a discreet thing
two there's two holes there yeah
and and yet you can deform the thing you
know you can allow all kinds of
continuous deformations but you can't
get rid of those two holes
there's no way to get rid of those two
holes so there's at the same time you've
got the continuity of the
of the manifold and the deformations
that you allow and you have this
discreteness
of two holes or like in a wave packet
you know it has all these continuous
things but it has a hump
it actually has a hump there some
localized concept
on on that by the way you heard it here
first manifolds are dimpled
they're like golf balls there's there's
a new hypothesis of adversarial examples
out
called the dimpled manifold hypothesis
and i'm sure you'll be hearing about
that
before long from here wait what no where
you didn't know about this
yannick doesn't check his email so this
is the first time in history
that i know more information than yet it
does
yannick will make a video about this
next week but you heard it from me first
who said that yeah so manifolds are like
dimples
manifolds are like dimples they've got
they've got little holes in don't tell
janet because it always really pisses me
off how yannick is so fast and
before i've even got a chance to read
something he's got a video out of this
no a new theory dimple yeah and it's not
you can't
easily explain you can't even access the
paper so nicholas carlini emailed us
about this
anyway i was i was saying that as you
say yannick there's a weird
there the thing is like on on the on the
continuous domain
it's it's all about interpolating right
and and in
in system two it's like you're running a
computer program
so there's such a weird interplay
between those two worlds
but anyway on that bombshell you're
getting scoop you're getting scooped tim
like yannick's gonna find that paper and
he's gonna make a video on send me the
page
can you promise not to make a golf ball
um video on adversarial examples
uh um before you do yeah i promise
i don't i won't make one before you do
i'll never forget when we did the
francois
yannick and i made a francois chalet
video and i i spent weeks doing my video
and yannick just like
he picked me to the post and that's the
only time yanick's really pissed me off
i wasn't even aware he wasn't even aware
you know because like he's just smearing
us over here it takes us a long time to
read papers
this is the problem when you have a
machine as a friend they they just
they're just doing their thing
you know grinding forward mechanism
exactly anyway on that bombshell
see you next week thanks bye-bye